Caption: how's everyone going decided anything
Caption: [Music]
Caption: first up this morning we have stopped
Caption: Percival's talking about the best
Caption: engineering is with the is good and bull
Caption: so for everyone so
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: and welcome to today s engineering
Caption: inexperience but hopefully appreciate it
Caption: it's a very difficult few down so
Caption: actually you guys ever you guys sorry
Caption: you'll get a special challenge today
Caption: these techniques go on I just wanted to
Caption: thank all the amazing sponsors and
Caption: probably all the stuff behind the scenes
Caption: got you know guiding people around
Caption: working AV here until you post 2018
Caption: today it's amazing privilege to be here
Caption: to speak to all today and possible
Caption: without everyone in this room also a
Caption: pioneer oh sorry let's go
Caption: yeah
Caption: [Music]
Caption: but any piece of software I will just
Caption: try and take it apart and see how far I
Caption: got
Caption: and I failed a lot of times during this
Caption: day there's nothing more frustrating
Caption: right that knowing you are doing the
Caption: wrong thing we're just going to have to
Caption: write like search query or the right
Caption: question to ask in order to actually get
Caption: back on the right track so yeah that was
Caption: us
Caption: after waddle after after you go around
Caption: the block I started my peak a few small
Caption: victories here in the man managed to
Caption: slowly kind of piece of keep things
Caption: together
Caption: more importantly I can start to see that
Caption: for all of these all of these reverse
Caption: engineering techniques though these
Caption: invisible kind of threads that were
Caption: connecting all the ones of the same type
Caption: and in fact like full really content
Caption: sheets the ones o I just kind of wrote
Caption: it off as bait all these deduce flight
Caption: weight out of my league there's actually
Caption: two or three steps for them is an easier
Caption: version of that same technique and by
Caption: practicing the skills and the transfer
Caption: it's very strange because rather stage
Caption: now where there's I guess so much
Caption: quality material especially in the form
Caption: of layups videos getting started rolls
Caption: and it all seems to be just kind of
Caption: focused on like the view from the top of
Caption: the mountain
Caption: so basically yeah as I said we're just
Caption: gonna talk about a little sitcom today
Caption: and hopefully with luck they'll just
Caption: give you the foothold you need to get
Caption: started so very good tool that could
Caption: begin with the definition for most
Caption: engineering it is a discipline that is
Caption: focused around gaining an understanding
Caption: that's pretty much it so we're talking
Caption: about say today obviously but when we
Caption: say system could be neat if we could
Caption: mean a secret pocket ship we could mean
Caption: a the kind of process could mean ice
Caption: cream play bug but all of these things
Caption: reverse engineer pretty much anything
Caption: man right and when we were posted to
Caption: doing it's important to have a doll you
Caption: don't the other thing it's up to you but
Caption: it's nice to have a goal so we know that
Caption: trying to get out of this experience and
Caption: a very common goal some people just
Caption: extract some information in the systems
Caption: sometimes you just feel like an
Caption: accretion cave or a DVD player or some
Caption: essence from a game just just getting
Caption: some information out other times you
Caption: might be doing some reverse engineering
Caption: components who trades or can improve on
Caption: a design you can make at the moment
Caption: that's really important especially if
Caption: you are trying to for instance credit
Caption: Oakland replacement for existing system
Caption: say like you know Lionel samih replacing
Caption: windows services I'm also the emulated
Caption: [Music]
Caption: now I'm not gonna pull the trap of
Caption: saying because challenging it is quite
Caption: challenging after let's kind of is
Caption: interesting it doesn't have to be is
Caption: impossible things I figured off too like
Caption: a select few people and unfortunately
Caption: like the longest time like as for us as
Caption: far as talking the world goes there's
Caption: been this kind of stagnant elitism
Caption: around the into my food over both
Caption: engineering and it suits me a little bit
Caption: so this is probably a good time to step
Caption: out some cancerous myths
Caption: loose it out loud talk about gates so
Caption: it's more just background noise it's the
Caption: idea that it is somehow
Caption: now somewhere that's probably gonna be I
Caption: guess platform documentation the API
Caption: console where you need to go to find
Caption: information everything else you can just
Caption: learn as you go
Caption: in fact it's probably gonna be quicker
Caption: than pre-loaded pre learning and in
Caption: front of dredger dollar another one that
Caption: comes up is also important to know EC is
Caption: not true there is an overlap between I
Caption: guess knowledge of how C works cqx keys
Caption: code
Caption: [Music]
Caption: and then finally like the Nauru Scotsman
Caption: fallacy the idea that it doesn't count
Caption: as regressive during unless it meets
Caption: some kind of ridiculous level of
Caption: planning groups that jump through and a
Caption: common one is that it just if someone
Caption: has a below done reverse engineering in
Caption: an area before doesn't
Caption: works usually there's more than one
Caption: person in succession and finally this is
Caption: a lot of kind of jumps with my pain
Caption: neurons the hottest Emily
Caption: reverse-engineering if it looks
Caption: sufficiently thankful and complex and
Caption: this one gets trafficked around so much
Caption: that I hate it because this is like this
Caption: is the root of why this started
Caption: exclusionary and self reinforcing or if
Caption: you are using reverse engineering
Caption: techniques so just very quickly talk
Caption: about three different categories of
Caption: technique there are three rough
Caption: categories you can fit every engineering
Caption: the three would be is blackbox analysis
Caption: which is basically just like messing
Caption: with the inputs and outputs that go into
Caption: a piece of software there's dynamic
Caption: analysis which is like sticking probes
Caption: into a piece of software as it runs to
Caption: figure out exactly what it's doing and
Caption: the state can also just kind of explain
Caption: the software out over on the table and
Caption: you try and just infer things from just
Caption: remaining what you have and it's always
Caption: going to have these two of these
Caption: approaches handy because generally
Caption: sometimes you might have all three if
Caption: you have all three that's brilliant but
Caption: a princess the moment I'm trying to
Caption: disassemble this boomer on this whole
Caption: synthesize that I have and the CPU
Caption: doesn't have goofy demos or come to
Caption: dynamic but I can't do the other two
Caption: just say and then I can change in
Caption: Florida which is Popoff's so if you have
Caption: less than two you and I have a difficult
Caption: time but at least two you're fine
Caption: now how am I gonna just get a show of
Caption: hands how many people would have done
Caption: something that was engineering how many
Caption: people specifically County people open
Caption: the network seven what's the traffic
Caption: coming in house sick all right you guys
Caption: sorry you've all done black post
Caption: engineering you've done my post analysis
Caption: right here I love the depth is this get
Caption: all three you get a post analysis
Caption: analysis inspector let's not focus on
Caption: that let's keep going all right sorry
Caption: today I'm gonna try a couple three
Caption: fairly complicated techniques one from
Caption: each of the categories this is it's
Caption: gonna be strongly the defense bit
Caption: between the accessible and the technical
Caption: so if I'm going too far off the deep end
Caption: please enter the opera's this is the
Caption: first time I've been kind of trying to
Caption: teach in this capacity before so it's
Caption: the only way that online so the first
Caption: few like I'm gonna talk about today is
Caption: something angel user one that's reading
Caption: mystery data now data comes from all
Caption: sorts of places when you reverse
Caption: engineer it can come from files it can
Caption: come from memory dumps become attractive
Caption: CAPTCHAs and we're very lucky and we
Caption: expanded format
Caption: we know and love like simple PNG or JSON
Caption: but usually we have to melt that lucky
Caption: and it just turns out to be just some
Caption: blow
Caption: so mr. Lowe we don't know a minute sorry
Caption: the question is how do we find out what
Caption: is in this mysterious mysterious balls
Caption: the answer is to go down a level sorry
Caption: Donovan boy spot is made up of lots of -
Caption: basically just you think of it as like a
Caption: single number between 0 and 255 or 8
Caption: bits or 0 0 2 FF in hexadecimal and 256
Caption: choices that's very small so I
Caption: thankfully there are a number of I guess
Caption: expanded ways of representing like
Caption: bigger things such as a lot of numbers
Caption: or Springs using the statements of box
Caption: and those are the contacts and codes so
Caption: there are a bunch of examples that or
Caption: some of the more popular ways of
Caption: encoding things advice you know two's
Caption: complement or negative integers in these
Caption: and such and of course we need some
Caption: tools to help us doing this kind of
Caption: thing is a hex editor now hexa to this
Caption: awful early reviews the hex editor at
Caption: some point if you're from a building
Caption: background the basics like text editors
Caption: but they just have this nice Big Bang is
Caption: showing you what the clock lab is inside
Caption: you always require they are amazing for
Caption: black box analysis you can do things
Caption: like any of them like get a program to
Caption: say 12 anything's and see how it reacts
Caption: maybe save before an opera change and
Caption: then trying to like command
Caption: is a difference and there were a lot of
Caption: pics tools out there and unfortunately
Caption: this very easy answer for which one is
Caption: the best
Caption: I must try them all eventually I will
Caption: find one that speaks to you and use that
Caption: I can make one piece of ice try and see
Caption: the dust statistics now for the
Caption: shameless plug part of the talk I really
Caption: quite like taking up complements and in
Caption: fact I was doing so long I got sick and
Caption: tired I made myself a library it is cool
Caption: a snooker table is a framework and the
Caption: idea basically there from binary file to
Caption: structure my motives to not get in you
Caption: know as few lines of code as possible so
Caption: and it also contains some cool
Caption: visualization tools which we're going to
Caption: be using in the next few slides just to
Caption: demo some stuff sorry if that thing
Caption: comes things sounds like gonna be either
Caption: speak to you at all by all means I urge
Caption: you to check it out alright so I think
Caption: it would be good at this point just kind
Caption: of short like a few examples of things
Caption: you can find
Caption: now we're talking before I thought I
Caption: guess standing files are useful because
Caption: in the stem initiative at not to use a
Caption: standard Bob it was this is another
Caption: point reinvent the wheel design my image
Caption: just there's a whole bunch of blog razor
Caption: to open game to you I'm afraid
Caption: bus at the same time companies really
Caption: just trust my message
Caption: trustus at the slide circuit if they use
Caption: a standard format sometimes they'll hide
Caption: it in something else but thankfully
Caption: worthless ID so we can dig little deeper
Caption: so is a random selection of standard
Caption: walls and all of them can be identified
Caption: by a magic number so I'll just come up
Caption: here a magic number is messages like
Caption: small sequences of bytes that happen
Caption: usually indicates is and this is the
Caption: Bristol bar you can see there's
Caption: definitely like a big pattern going
Caption: along here you can see like these large
Caption: Rosa it seems like cruising all right be
Caption: proof support and in text that's pretty
Caption: much what they are these are all kind of
Caption: these are these who've been introduced
Caption: so four bytes is representing one number
Caption: and normally don't be like enough of the
Caption: discovery of the fact that this is just
Caption: actually the numbers 353 in fact there
Caption: are 353 list entries after that oh sorry
Caption: we see here but they are going up in
Caption: size and they are less than the total
Caption: size of the file which is a game archive
Caption: sorry that could be that could be those
Caption: significance people were to pick one of
Caption: these and then jumps with a spot of the
Caption: file which corresponds to the number
Caption: clearly like some game data that they
Caption: didn't want us to see and then and you
Caption: know just to talk about the next group
Caption: there's another group before actually
Caption: the breasts are the sizes and so you
Caption: would see this exact kind of lab but
Caption: it's a good example of I guess it's used
Caption: quite a lot especially in situations
Caption: where you don't have very much memory
Caption: because this is very cheap and it easy
Caption: for the CPU to kind of like to load of
Caption: days just straight from the disk and
Caption: iterating through them and it's also
Caption: pretty lazy bug prevention relax and
Caption: programmers love these because there's
Caption: no validation is jump ms around the
Caption: bottle using things but yes
Caption: this is this is normal of one general
Caption: thumb is if you see something in the
Caption: heck stuff that looks sort of like a
Caption: picture it probably actually is as we
Caption: said before that's like basically you
Caption: know we would be matching the standard
Caption: ball or damaged bus at the same time and
Caption: take a look there are real pain to
Caption: actually use so much you just want a
Caption: graphic right and this here is an
Caption: example about the 256 colors so
Caption: everybody is one pixel
Caption: there's a high speed in somewhere else
Caption: inside
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so that's like a really interesting
Caption: property I guess over because it's like
Caption: a wave and it's always kind of going up
Caption: and above the origin points of the sound
Caption: wave it means these really nice
Caption: symmetrical distributions and it works
Caption: but but for pretty much any type of any
Caption: number that you put into that so you see
Caption: something we've made this is basic mr.
Caption: Graham I'm sorry
Caption: video impetus but one pole what every
Caption: single violence is counting the number
Caption: of H so if you have a histogram looks
Caption: perfectly symmetrical and in fact I was
Caption: procrastinating with rather than as well
Caption: so actually made another school
Caption: I really like the histogram so I made
Caption: another tool which would just go through
Caption: fall slice it up and give you a
Caption: histogram that each line that was
Caption: actually I quite enjoy this because you
Caption: can from this you can actually kind of
Caption: make
Caption: what's in the file without actually
Caption: seeing anything it like for instance and
Caption: the bridge hope you see there's a nice
Caption: big square in the second quadrant of the
Caption: top line and that happens to be sitting
Caption: cauldron happens to be mobile the
Caption: esqueleto zealots are all the alphabet
Caption: characters and balloon oh yes its ASCII
Caption: text to that area underneath that kind
Caption: of tapestry monstrosity underneath
Caption: that's actually x86 courage this game is
Caption: pretty always fun with sound rise with
Caption: it basically but you can tell that it's
Caption: kind of toy because it's not only
Caption: depressed and let these long things I'd
Caption: like to instructions which are the most
Caption: popular now underneath that we
Caption: [Music]
Caption: compressed kind of just to go back and
Caption: kind of see that it's not fully solo
Caption: reasons compressed well so it's been
Caption: personally badly you can still make out
Caption: some detail but at school there's no
Caption: black areas which means that he is
Caption: compressed to some degree and then a
Caption: right hand side tone as we said before
Caption: it is symmetrical is probably audio and
Caption: there you can see that try to apply the
Caption: Kraken compression to that which is why
Caption: there's a noise on the side but because
Caption: and then finally guys sir when you kind
Caption: of see this this is probably the point
Caption: at which black box analysis of kind of
Caption: brought its colas sorry
Caption: and so basically this is the same file
Caption: compressing entry vehicle place and you
Caption: know what I'm lefty is based compression
Caption: and the blog rot is the same button with
Caption: like RSA encryption applied so if the
Caption: histograms probably sweat it means it's
Caption: indistinguishable amendment was posted
Caption: on us it's been encrypted but some and
Caption: yet assimilate it doesn't like Billy in
Caption: this Daily Post article Walter entropy
Caption: in the encrypted was and at this point
Caption: you can't really just determine how it's
Caption: compressed hopefully about looking for
Caption: the right lens I strongly encourage you
Caption: to just open up every single bottle
Caption: alright so secondly I want to talk about
Caption: troubleshooting any problem a very key
Caption: pot of reverse engineering in the
Caption: software space is just inspecting the
Caption: code as it runs it's an extremely
Caption: so in the engineering is just as if you
Caption: have which is to say it's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: today is almost guaranteed to be in all
Caption: the wine which is what quite nice but
Caption: there are like a couple of downsides
Caption: first one is to keep in except election
Caption: you betta Margie behold
Caption: you'll get 1291 lines of text
Caption: pumpkins number of beaches you're never
Caption: going to use
Caption: I'd like to make two things first what
Caption: we're going on mostly focusing on one
Caption: specific you can't just learn one you've
Caption: got to kind of be able to roll with it
Caption: and quick to weightless the best 1p
Caption: platform white princess if you're on an
Caption: emulator don't go to that and you want
Caption: to use the pain rather than the system
Caption: one but it's not quite as bad on being a
Caption: little melodramatic here because out of
Caption: all of that you just need to learn how
Caption: to unroll of HSA you just need to know
Caption: how to use the rest of cool with you
Caption: know how to use the rest but zone yoga
Caption: for futures you really need to know is I
Caption: guess I can't escape Dakota so how to
Caption: move backwards and forwards and continue
Caption: new gonna has set breakpoints obviously
Caption: so be able to stop
Caption: [Music]
Caption: and bumpy's one of those cases where
Caption: it's where I was talking about before
Caption: you can basically practice you can
Caption: practice through using it and the skills
Caption: will transfer over to the slightly out
Caption: of your hand so some of the best
Caption: training you can get for reverse
Caption: engineering so it'll make you better
Caption: moving around the program shopping your
Caption: investigative wits and later on when you
Caption: have the sources I just want to quickly
Caption: run through I do share parenting
Caption: this isn't prescriptive you do not have
Caption: to follow this to the letter it's more
Caption: than you by the way so these are the
Caption: steps basically firstly first step is
Caption: always to come track reduced behavior in
Caption: a testing run so behind beautiful sweet
Caption: like a problem or a feature to
Caption: investigate quite often this is the
Caption: hottest step which is actually getting
Caption: to run
Caption: but secondly is to establish some
Caption: boundaries of the system if your system
Caption: is using a bunch of saying like helper
Caption: libraries make sure that you can kind of
Caption: like I guess either include them or
Caption: eliminate them using spell it's about
Caption: like I'm fencing off the curves of just
Caption: a bit that you won't investigate
Caption: pretty much the ones message to observe
Caption: for points of interest now point of
Caption: interest would be anything that kind of
Caption: anything interesting that happens any
Caption: kind of students that would happen for
Caption: instance during a problem where the
Caption: specific voiding of an error message and
Caption: the monitor is a you're trying to kind
Caption: of figure out I guess what state inside
Caption: the program is flipping between good and
Caption: bad
Caption: I mean visit there's a specific check
Caption: that's fairly but quite making notice
Caption: but what that check is and then just
Caption: make like a short list a piece of these
Caption: things
Caption: well this define an entry point close to
Caption: one of these points of interest so an
Caption: entry point is just literally open up
Caption: the program that the buggah place of
Caption: breakpoints at love these things and
Caption: step three and finally trace through to
Caption: the exact moment that it actually
Caption: happens so this is basically Ferguson
Caption: just comes in through the code keep in
Caption: mind any of that states why don't you
Caption: grab a point let's butchers we look too
Caption: bad if you do find a spot where it has
Caption: kind of good to bad work backwards
Caption: trying to figure out what is cool is
Caption: that chain of events to reach that that
Caption: specific spot to find out what pulls the
Caption: check to me Boston for instance and
Caption: that's that's pretty much it
Caption: when you have a source card it is by
Caption: practicing this again it's just about
Caption: catching in the muscle memory the
Caption: moments and when you have no soul scars
Caption: the procedure is pretty much exactly the
Caption: same
Caption: [Music]
Caption: modifications I highly encourage you
Caption: just get as much practice as possible if
Caption: you can't just just challenge yourself
Caption: because favorite open source project
Caption: that you otherwise just kind of was
Caption: being too hot and trying to fix above
Caption: even a crazy amount finally one Eric
Caption: discussion this is how to understand any
Caption: pages I was just like power-mad on
Caption: possibilities that would open up and
Caption: he's just it seemed such like a great
Caption: thing and sorry it took me about several
Caption: types of ideas to be truly comfortable
Caption: with it and I just let's talk about
Caption: let's talk a bit about assembly language
Caption: as you might a cold as motor pool we're
Caption: building about you can break down in the
Caption: assembly language but it won't be fully
Caption: you can only see through this tiny
Caption: window about this tiny window that
Caption: follows with our progress is in the very
Caption: principle to make any kind of
Caption: [Music]
Caption: language is also is underneath there'll
Caption: be some aesthetic dog which is like old
Caption: stack of strings and such memory of
Caption: course we need members who they'll be
Caption: like a penis attack of temperature Marie
Caption: at one of the averages but is the stack
Caption: and course the program can ask the
Caption: operating system for more memory when
Caption: it's running so every time it does that
Caption: it will have a new statement allocation
Caption: it's here talking about the operators we
Caption: also need to include the entire
Caption: operating system kernel
Caption: just in case we need one thing from
Caption: antara braces and then the same ones
Caption: also causing us to income calamities so
Caption: obviously we have shin Barbies that we
Caption: use in this program they're gonna have a
Caption: signal as well
Caption: now that's the address space elevator
Caption: now CPA sorry I'm late no a little
Caption: steeper the most CPUs of kind of work
Caption: exactly the same but bear with me on
Caption: this because knowing that I'm different
Caption: but you can make you can make a bunch of
Caption: assumptions about how CP was going over
Caption: it's going to be a bunch of registers
Caption: these places just variables right but it
Caption: holds like one number one memory address
Caption: and these are used for nice and just
Caption: like you know math or reading or writing
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you have general purpose registers and
Caption: the love you like a couple special wants
Caption: to it like this voice up gonna be a
Caption: special register which points to where
Caption: we will always be that so every time we
Caption: execute instructions in program council
Caption: of it forwards there'll always be a
Caption: Flags registers so this is kind of how
Caption: if statements and such our evaluator
Caption: will see you basically every time an
Caption: instruction runs it will change the
Caption: flags register based on say
Caption: philosophy question is this value 0
Caption: value
Caption: [Music]
Caption: that's interesting so well shared
Caption: libraries again so obviously to do many
Caption: of these things it's going to call
Caption: either the shared library or the kernel
Caption: and these are public made guys which
Caption: means we still have the names now for
Caption: the for the most probably disassembly
Caption: something unless you're really lucky and
Caption: you get a debug version you're not gonna
Caption: be able to see me the next week we'll be
Caption: able to see where all of these public
Caption: you guys have been cold and it's
Caption: incredibly useful for instance sounds
Caption: trying to kind of figure out how all the
Caption: way was working to go and say okay so
Caption: there's 29,000 different
Caption: [Music]
Caption: as you can see basically sees they
Caption: really want you to use their that city
Caption: news right so one of the tools they'll
Caption: provide you is a document called an
Caption: instruction set breakfast every single
Caption: instruction in the CPU actually does
Caption: this PDF ranking text file in another
Caption: window and you copy each line into
Caption: whatever format you need to think the
Caption: least about so - like like if it goes
Caption: through 32 US aid but basically just
Caption: like by the line convert it sounds
Caption: slurred and back-breaking but you have
Caption: two advantages
Caption: interesting as we've established you can
Caption: filter out the things that are no
Caption: interesting quite quickly and secondly
Caption: it's basically that it sounds slow but
Caption: trust me here it's actually bigger than
Caption: just like staring at something written
Caption: in this dream moon language and in front
Caption: of the pond where it is just being very
Caption: rough like this but afterwards you can
Caption: ship away but you slowly add more of all
Caption: things that you found out and just to
Caption: just be clear this is like a tiny
Caption: snippet the actual function that it's
Caption: what this poem is about 300 lines we
Caption: don't have that in here but from that
Caption: you can trace through you can slowly
Caption: figure out I guess what the inputs the
Caption: outputs when we play those back up the
Caption: chain and you get upper pastas
Caption: formations you get something like this
Caption: and you can kind of make out where the
Caption: you can't make that way the other
Caption: variables were staying from but again if
Caption: you have the entire function that you
Caption: can transfer you can slowly even if it's
Caption: the no correct guesses really that's all
Caption: there is to it once you have that entry
Caption: point from which you can make more
Caption: discoveries and cross-check that with a
Caption: lot of code on the debugger you this is
Caption: basically that you can read any program
Caption: and much like much like the buggy the
Caption: school just comes with I guess amount of
Caption: time spent will you get more confident
Caption: and experience the more times you try
Caption: this even if you don't succeed so if
Caption: this sounds like something you ever
Caption: wanted to try
Caption: I recommend just giving it a shot just
Caption: once just to see unfortunately always at
Caption: the end of time here today but if
Caption: there's one thing that I hope to kind of
Caption: like shed and like people to take away
Caption: today it's the idea that it's possible
Caption: to get started in some of the very
Caption: hottest areas of reverse engineering
Caption: without knowing very much but you can
Caption: feel the side much stronger I'm ready to
Caption: progress up the chain to complicated
Caption: things and in closing I just wanted to
Caption: say the best absolute best over that is
Caption: reverse engineering
Caption: it's just passionately there's once
Caption: basically this is truly to do with
Caption: perseverance outlays absolutely
Caption: everything including skill and
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: all the fever's proudly serving officer
Caption: pain question what's the people who were
Caption: most proud for best engineering or okay
Caption: I'm probably the thing that I like the
Caption: most is on reverse you know Macromedia
Caption: director yeah at the moment I'm trying
Caption: to kind of work on the engine for that
Caption: scummvm most of just because not sure a
Caption: lot of you what they were this kind of
Caption: this great series of educational games
Caption: by some reason Duncan and but for the
Caption: longest time like I painted this King
Caption: started there was like a streaming
Caption: version that they were getting and it
Caption: just didn't seem as been I thought well
Caption: I wanted to work on this company in
Caption: Manhattan
Caption: it's make sense right to preserve the
Caption: things before that in this particular
Caption: series was critically acclaimed the only
Caption: month cement industry come on site
Caption: absolutely no one is going to view it
Caption: unless someone steps up knows it yeah
Caption: I guess that would like depend on the
Caption: exact agreement that you what was the
Caption: what was the exact sequester it's
Caption: actually feasible to distribute the
Caption: results of your work kind of straight
Caption: pre-made question to the recording just
Caption: natural so if you are reverse engineer I
Caption: mean you want to share the results of
Caption: that are there any legal implications I
Caption: think so long as your solution doesn't
Caption: actually incorporate all the parts
Caption: itself
Caption: one more and then inside of the morning
Caption: say I can't believe it that everyone
Caption: please remember you'll lead back it's
Caption: really important to be able to win any
Caption: of the prizes you need to give you
Caption: feedback and morning tea is available us
Caption: as
Caption: you
Caption: [Applause]